hey this is presto Walker from each
corner of a parallelogram draw two line
segments to connect the corner to the
midpoints of the opposite sides these
eight line segments bound in octagon
what is the ratio of the octagons area
to the parallelograms area this
challenging problem was given to eighth
grade students in Russia now one of the
difficulties of this problem is even
trying to draw the diagram so let me get
that started for you we start out with
the parallelogram now from each corner
we'll draw two line segments to connect
the corner to the midpoints of the
opposite sides we need to do that for
each of the four corners of the
parallelogram in total we've drawn eight
line segments and these line segments
bound in octagon the question is what is
the ratio of the octagons area to the
parallelograms area can you figure it
out give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution so I hope you've given this
problem a try and before I present the
solution I'm going to admit that I could
not solve this problem there's just too
much information and I wasn't able to
figure out the way to approach this
problem to figure out the areas so
what's the correct answer the answer is
1/6 the amazing thing is that the answer
applies for any parallelogram which will
include rectangles and even squares so I
was stumped by this problem but how
would an eighth grader figure it out
well I looked up some solutions online
and there are many different ways you
could do it some involving more
complicated mathematical methods
the method I will present in this video
uses only basic geometric principles the
solution was emailed to me by Michael
Kay who also suggested the problem so
the idea is to consider the
parallelogram and divide it even to even
smaller parallelograms and we'll end up
finding some patterns the first step is
to slice the octagon like a pizza into
four pieces of equal area by connecting
opposite midpoints of the parallelogram
let me get started with some notation
let P be the parallelograms area and let
X equal the octagons area we're
searching for the ratio X over P so how
is dividing this parallelogram going to
help us well each quarter of the octagon
has an equal area therefore each quarter
will be equal to x over 4 next we've
divided the parallelogram into four
smaller parallelograms and each of these
will have 1/4 the area of the
parallelogram so each of these will be P
over 4 now what we'll do is we'll take
one of these smaller parallelograms and
then we'll do the same thing so let's
zoom into the parallelogram in the upper
right quadrant
let's now connect the midpoints of
opposite side in this parallelogram to
divide it into four smaller
parallelograms each of these four
smaller parallelograms love one quarter
the area of the previous small
parallelogram so one fourth of P over
four will be P over sixteen now we're
going to do this even one more time
let's focus on one of these smaller
parallelograms and let's zoom in one
more time let's focus on just this
parallelogram and what happens if we
connect midpoints on opposite sides of
this parallelogram
once again we're getting closer to the
area of this quarter of the octagon so
we again have four smaller
parallelograms that'll be one quarter
the area of the previous parallelograms
so one quarter of P over 16 will be P
over 64 so we figured out one portion of
the quarter of this octagon we now can
look at the rest of the portions of the
octagon in this little grid in the next
grid just above we have a portion of the
octagon which is a trapezoid now this
trapezoid will have an area that's 3/4
of the area of this small parallelogram
so it'll be 3/4 of P over 64 this is
because each trapezoid is a small
parallelogram minus a triangle that has
1/4 the area of the small parallelogram
in other words this portion is 3/4 times
P over 64 and we also have another
trapezoid that's going to be 3/4 times P
over 64
so we now have one final piece of the
Octagon in this grid so what's this area
well look at the shape of this area if
we expand it and scale it up it's
exactly going to be one quarter of the
Octagon and we can scale it back down in
other words this last piece is a
scaled-down shape of the 1/4 slice of
the octagon as we've scaled by 1/4 2
times that means the area of the
scale-down piece will be 1/4 times 1/4
times x over 4 which is 1/4 of the
octagon therefore this will be X divided
by 64 so we're now pretty much ready to
solve the problem we have one expression
for the area of 1/4 of the octagon as x
over 4 and we've just figured out
another expression for 1/4 of the
Octagon
it'll be the sum of these areas that's P
over 64 plus 2 times the area of a
trapezoid which is 3/4 times P over 64
plus X over 64 because these expressions
both represent the area of 1/4 of the
octagon we can set these expressions
equal to each other
we can now bring the terms of X on the
left in terms of P on the right we can
then simplify and then we can divide
through to get that the ratio of x over
P is equal to 1/6 and that's our answer
so I hope you could follow all of those
steps with the zooming in but in case
you didn't let me just present it on one
slide we divide the parallelogram by
connecting midpoints of opposite sides
this gives 1/4 slice of the octagon into
each of these parallelograms so if X
over 4 as each of these quarter slices
we then divide the upper right quadrant
or any of these quadrants one more time
by connecting the midpoints and then we
do it one more time we then have one
quarter slice of the octagon in this
small little grid of four parallelograms
the smallest parallelogram will have an
area of P over 64 due to the scaling we
can then figure out the area the
trapezoids as three fourths of the area
the small parallelogram and then we have
just one more shape and that's going to
be similar to the entire one quarters
slice of the octagon therefore we know
this will be equal to x over 64 so we've
deduced two different ways to figure out
the area of one quarter slice of the
octagon we set these two expressions
equal to each other and then solve for
the ratio of x over P to be 1/6 so it's
a remarkable solution that only depends
on connecting the midpoints of the
parallelogram and then deducing the rest
of the areas from basic geometric
principles did you figure it out and
which method did you use to solve this
problem thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math you can catch me on my
blog mind your decisions which you can
follow on Facebook Google+ and patreon
you can catch me on social media at
pressure Locker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description